the next gentlemen I am privileged to
introduce is one of the film's most
distinguished creative artists a man who
was himself won Oscars for his direction
of mrs. Miniver our best years of our
lives and been her three awards for
films he made the hard way with actors
ladies and gentlemen mr. William Wyler
thank you by the way for the two Oscars
given Billy Wilder I should be accepting
a lot of compliments for it the Academy
Board of Governors has voted an award to
one of our great stars the citation
reads to Gary Cooper for as many
memorable screen performances as well as
the international recognition as an
individual has gained for himself and
the motion picture industry this is
highly deserved and I see a highly
privileged to present it
four men would never as much to say no
one has ever said more to the credit of
our industry than Gary Cooper and more
than that to our country because Gary
Cooper represents the type of American
who is loved in the four corners of the
earth contrary to popular belief who is
not a shy man he's a humble man he has
humility a great lost art and not to
begin fears with weakness it comes
through vividly on the screen and off
many people including Cooper don't
realize what a fine actor he really is
there's a rare and unique talent in two
more with a look or a turn of the head
than most new Vogue's waves and methods
his style is movie acting at its very
best the Academy gives this us and all
its love in reverse order to mr. Gary
Cooper
or the award will be accepted by a close
friend and a worthy standing mr. Jimmy
Stewart
I'm very honored to accept this award
for Gary Cooper I'm only sorry that he
wasn't here tonight to accept it in
person but I know that he's sitting
beside his television set tonight so
cope I'll get this to you right away and
Cooper I want you to know this that with
this goes all the warm friendship and
the affection and the admiration and the
deep the deep respect of all of us we're
we're very very proud of you coop all of
us are tremendously proud
you